Speaker 1: Mike Pence is having a tough go of it.
Mike Pence appeared on a radio program yesterday
and. Mike Pence, as you may know, has not
committed to pardoning Donald Trump. If Trump
were to be indicted on any of these various
indictments that he is facing and possibly
future indictments, the host didn't like it
and confronted Mike Pence. And it actually
is is quite interesting. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: Ultimate decider. With all due respect,
when you aren't telling us what your decision
would be, I think you're dodging the question
and frankly, not stepping up on the on the front
of leadership, which in the past you've been
willing to do. So to me, not answering is a no.
Speaker 4: Well, look, I that's number one. I
don't think you know what the president's defense
is, do you? I mean, what are the facts? I mean,
look, we either believe in our judicial
process in this country or we don't. We stand
by the rule of law. We don't. I just what
I would tell you is I think as someone to.
Speaker 2: Watch, what I'm hearing is you're
fine with Donald Trump being put in prison,
sir. And that, to me, since you were his
vice president, feels pretty disrespectful.
Speaker 4: I had a standard rule. I don't talk
about hypotheticals. Look, we don't know what the
president's defense here is. I think he's entitled
to make his defense entitled to have his day in
court. And look, let's you know, let's take it one
step at a time. But I would just tell you that I.
Speaker 2: What if you know that these
are political charges and you do. This
is not a this is not a difficult decision. I think
we make. I think we've gotten I think we've gotten
what we're going to get here in terms of an.
Speaker 4: Answer to this one. Yeah, I just.
Speaker 1: Think this is the day because the
Clay and Buck show and the cohost is like,
yeah, we we probably should move on.
Speaker 4: I think any conclusion by
anyone running for the presidency of
the United States that would prejudge
the facts in this case.
Speaker 2: Or prejudge.
Speaker 4: The investigation into President
Biden or his family is premature. Let's let
let's let the process play out. Let's
follow the facts. And I promise you, as
president of the United States, I'll do just that.
Speaker 1: So, you know, the bar is extremely low.
I want to say to you, this is more or less the
right answer, but it's only more or less the
right answer Once we've adjusted our expectations
and put the bar really, really low around Mike
Pence. And case in point, three weeks ago,
Pence was singing a different tune when the
indictment was the one out of New York. Pence only
recently changed his tune. We reported this to you
yesterday. Mike Pence has sudden change of heart
over Trump classified documents. I can't defend
it. Having read the indictment, these are very
serious allegations, Pence told the Wall Street
Journal's editorial board Tuesday. So in one
sense, Pence is correct. Why on earth would I
tell you now I'm going to pardon someone
when they haven't even put on a defense?
They certainly haven't been convicted. We just
don't have enough information. The counterpoint
from the hosts is if you concede the charges
are merely political in nature, then does it
really matter what the defense is? Wouldn't you be
inclined to say that you're going to pardon Donald
Trump because the bar is so low? It is 2023. I'm
not going to pretend that we're in the nineties
or late eighties or whenever the bar is so low
that I'm willing to give Pence some credit for
saying to this guy, You're not going to get me to
say right now that I'm going to pardon Trump. The
question that becomes increasingly interesting is
we're seeing a split among Republican candidates,
some who say I would absolutely pardon Trump and
others who say, no, I wouldn't, or at least I
can't commit to that right now. That is becoming
a clash between the candidates. And it will be
very interesting to see if that issue comes up
in the debates, which will be starting in August.